salut c'est la dernière vidéo sur la
mémoire de l'année est ce que vous voyez
ce que c'est ça dans le fond oui c'est
une chaise mais pas n'importe quel
chaise puisque c'est une chaire
directeur du youtube le youtube
il est beau les youtube une remise de
prix le youtube space et j'ai gagné
quelque chose
et du coup ils m'ont envoyé ça et ce
genre de conneries j'aime bien alors je
filme comme ça parce que j'ai encore
oublié mon pied de caméra pour changer
et en parlant d'oubli aujourd'hui on va
parler du fait d'oublier d'arrêter
d'oublier parce qu'il faut arrêter
d'oublier génériques
cette année je vous ai fait aussi des
vidéos sur la mémoire qu'on peut
retrouver dans la playlist truc de
mémoire et je pense que la dernière peut
parler aisément du fait qu'il faut pas
oublier ce qu'on a appris c'est bien
d'avoir des méthodes pour aller
consolidé c'est mieux il faut savoir
quand même que notre mémoire à court
terme
elle fonctionne aux environs de 18
secondes c'est donc très rapide avec
toutes les méthodes et les techniques on
a vu cette année on retient plus
longtemps et plus efficacement parce
qu'on crée les connexions entre plein de
choses on n'a pas juste un bien qui mène
à une information mais des dizaines de
liens dans tous les sens ces images et
ce avec des souvenirs c'est plus
efficace ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
pas réviser sauf que j'aime pas trop
bien le mot rêver on va dire qu'il faut
réactiver régulièrement la formation
pour ça il ya plusieurs techniques
lesquels je peux vous le dire je vais
vous dire lesquelles
mais avant de bien vous dire lesquelles
voyons quand même bien apprendre quand
vous voulez apprendre efficacement peu
importe la méthode que vous utilisez
vous avez besoin d'un temps de
concentration ce temps de concentration
en fait il fait un pic
on va dire qu'il ya un démarrage
qu'après il ya un espèce d'âge d'or
durant certains minutage et après sa
naissance sec la réelle capacité
d'apprentissage et entre 20 et 45
minutes pourra mettre humain normalement
constitué le seul moyen de bien
apprendre et d'être dans ce temps de
concentration jusque là on est tous
d'accord et bien sachez qu'une fois on a
fini notre âge d'or de concentration que
tout est redescendu qu'on n'arrive plus
à prendre
on a on a complètement perdu notre élan
et on pourra pas le reprendre mais c'est
la seule méthode qu'on connaît puisque
c'est celle qui organisait en cours par
exemple qu'on vous fait un cours d'une
heure deux heures
la bonne méthode d'apprentissage c'est
de faire une pause en plein âge d'or et
de reprendre après puisqu'on est déjà
échauffée on va reprendre et refaire une
pause et c'est le bon timing est celui
que je recommande depuis des années et
c'est celui que je pratique pour moi
c'est 20 minutes d'apprentissage cinq
minutes de pause
en fait c'est super efficace et c'est
beaucoup vous avez fait
20 minutes d'apprentissage 5 de
pots-de-vin d'apprentissage 5 de
pots-de-vin d'apprentissage 5,2 pose
autant de fois que vous le souhaitez
sauf que les 20 minutes d'apprentissage
c'est sans ordinateur téléphone coupé
sans aucune distraction et les cinq
minutes de pause elles sont top chrono
c'est 5 20 minutes vous pouvez aller
manger un morceau vous pouvez vous
dégourdir les jambes écouter la musique
passer un coup de téléphone mais cinq
minutes seulement et vous reprenez
pareil en recoupant toute distraction
si vous arrivez à faire ça en 1h15 vous
aurez eu une heure d'apprentissage et de
concentration réel et quinze minutes de
pause alors que si vous aviez fait une
heure d'affilée
au bout de 45 minutes vous auriez tout
perdu les 15 minutes d'après elle aurait
été complètement inefficace et encore je
vous dis 45 minutes pour les meilleurs
d'entre nous il y en a au bout de vingt
ou vingt-cinq ou trente minutes c'est
déjà fini
et vous n'auriez pas pu reprendre alors
que là vous auriez pu continuer ce cycle
sur deux heures et demi pour apprendre
deux heures efficacement et une bonne
méthode d'apprentissage et te faire de
l'apprentissage croisés c'est à dire de
ne pas se concentrer durant des jours et
des heures et des heures que sur un
sujet spécifique là aussi une croyance
populaire qui dit on doit être focus sur
un seul objectif non plus vous allez
multiplier les choses plus vous allez
aussi cité de l'intérêt de la
concentration et vous allez est efficace
donc vous pouvez faire 20 minutes de
quelque chose vingt minutes d'autres
choses 20 minutes d'autres choses et
tourner comme ça en boucle sur deux
heures et demi ou sur trois heures 45
etc etc
vous pouvez faire des cycles autant que
vous voulez une fois qu'on a appris il
faut donc réaliser je voulais dit j'aime
pas le mort est visé parce que déjà je
trouve qu'il renvoie des mauvaises
énergies à des mauvais souvenirs en fait
faut juste rollier vous pouvez relire
régulièrement tout ce que vous avez fait
si vous avez fait les my maps
relisez les mailles mal ça va réactiver
l'info si ce sont des choses plus
traditionnels relisez les simplement
ne cherchez pas à réapprendre relisez et
la technique ultime pour relire et pour
se rappeler c'est les flashs cas je vous
ai fait une vidéo sur la flash carte que
je vais vous remettre sûrement ici
enfin au dessus de moi et dans la
description étudier ça m'était ça en
place ça prend pas trop longtemps vous
pouvez aussi utiliser un
un bullet journal pour ceux qui s'en
sert peut-être vous connaissez pas le
bullet journal si c'est le cas
renseignez vous un petit peu si vous
voulez une vidéo là dessus par les uns
dans les commentaires c'est un outil
hyper efficace pour s'organiser pour la
créativité pour se donner des objectifs
comme ça de d'apprentissage long terme
et de réactivation c'est bien je m'égare
revenons au flash cards essayé de mettre
ça en place parce qu'en même temps
s'organise un peu votre timing si vous
utilisez la vraie méthode du classement
des flashs car voilà c'était les petits
conseils de fin d'année 2 fabien sur la
mémoire j'espère que ça vous a plu si
c'est le cas n'oubliez pas de lire la
vidéo et de vous abonner rendez vous
demain à 11 heures demain
[Musique]